Michael Rob we are playing halo 5 and
there is a new mode today or yesterday
flow fight it was a 55 they live them
again and we're gonna be playing it and
checking it out um we played a couple so
far it's fun it's enjoyable mm-hmm tough
yeah can be tough um you know it's
essentially waves of enemies and with
objectives and and methods of destroying
them scattered throughout a play yeah so
far it's been it's cut they've they've
changed it up every time right you don't
know what type of wave you're going to
get but it could be anything from kill
grunts kill X amount of grunts defend
minibosses do ya mini-bosses towards the
end it we you know you have like a at
least last time we had a ward and we had
to take down yeah but they change it up
enough where you don't know what you can
get into more or less yeah there's
variety for sure yeah all right well
this has been kind of the same
yeah it starts off you're just kind of
storming the beach kind of like a silent
cartographer yeah
like right now type deal to get through
these quick you want get your Rex up
ASAP yeah you want to be aggressive for
sure
but it's cool i like seeing one of my
immediate likes is seeing all you know
all these you get to see people's armor
yeah such as red versus blue right right
I mean you know you really only see what
you look like in the menu but now I get
to show off what you Joe rockin show off
what your economic gave you that's
exactly right exactly right yeah so you
see our counter at the bottom right we
need 75 total grunt kills eventually
they'll go far they'll start popping up
with indicators but I haven't seen that
yet I don't know what I don't know when
that happens but it's it's within like
five or ten or something okay and I
think got it
only a couple targets left yeah there
you know you nailed it it's like I
nailed its face nice that wallet Jesus
nah nah Deb sweet little trees round
complete man it's French for 20 nice and
all right let's see what we get
yeah no shows three that battle right
stupid one so let's see what's new if
it's the so Mike you and I played one
before we lost yeah due to a objective
which was you know defend this garage
and they smoked us warm it was a bunch
of the Prometheans actually this is
think this is the same one yeah it's so
far this has been like the same fired
the race right now we're just
eliminating these mini bosses because it
doesn't say like the front of garage or
anything yeah yeah oh man this gets
toughest tonight like bad like if you're
not if you don't get back into cover
fast you're done yeah there are eight of
us just to reiterate they're a bunch of
us but it can be tough the next I think
that's max right a people yeah
which for halo is a lot yeah but it
makes sense i mean there are tons of
dudes here right Jesus oh hey how are
you gentle needs oh yeah
six a shotgun em all right now that's
not helpful no oh see if anybody died up
here you take their weapon yeah no no no
no will you come from oh I got killed a
crawler ah [ __ ] you I mean three yet I
got step it up
oh he should know foundation dude the
sniper they're everywhere ah thought I
was in cover means crawlers are so
aggressive oh yeah dog carbine all right
what some terrible cheese red confirmed
what's next defending this garage
probably from the invading hell spawn
dude I got feeling that's what it is
intermission smoke em if you got yep
this is it right I'm gonna Oh see this
is that they just spawn right in there
super oh yeah oh it's coop and he's
still here Who fans back oh no do the
Atlanta Motor they come look at this
they come right behind you all right
let's get let's get wit let's get
creative Mike ah yep come in there we go
there we go crawler kills oh god I look
at it I gotta get out of here oh yeah if
you're done how you're done dude if
you're in there you're done something
alive somehow loyal it's a glitch its
scale glitch
for that damn night at batch on it um
come to mind us again another crawler
all right I'm out I'm out do they are
they chase you too yeah they really do
they love it all tonight this few nights
coming in now darn fog oh oh no I should
reload it before you need my help
coming out this night somebody yeah
that's a night exp who's got a shot
right upstairs downstairs still another
fit we're halfway how they're not down
sir I'm Island owl says they're up I'm a
damn ovarium night I have a feeling
they're gonna come in again from behind
the egg and then I kills for some PX
here there we go there's a little 6lu me
whoa busy alcohol [ __ ] a bunch of nice
respond upstairs oh and now they're
coming it here they come in downstairs
yes I would I don't know if they're
coming down so I'm out of ammo oh dude
there oh that's impossible they are
everywhere [ __ ] is up I mean it's I
don't know I don't know I feel about it
it's like no mercy you know they're just
everywhere alright so yeah um I got us
some feedback and we got 30 more yeah we
so it's got two and a half and then it's
to do it should be fine oh my god
they're just in there I don't even know
what to do anymore oh god but i really
needed better better weapons
lobbing grenades into them oh my god
no my sorry we're laying it on now we
got all eight of us here oh we all good
that's not scattered showers from behind
all right let's uh the power up and go
and what do I want yo Hydra
just get a rape see ya little annoyed I
hope man oh man it's done I'm just
hitting those crawlers now it is yet
there's level eight efforts just spawn
wanted to show them my toy
intermission I will light rifle instead
actually that
ya know for that what's up like a doc
busca vasa I love your costs yep how you
get in to get in my god another read
what yours are Wraith this is a 98 yeah
I'd say that goodbye I hate sitting in
turret seats i'm gonna get bugged mm-hmm
gonna go can go very smoothly here we go
all there right oh man that could have
been awesome and I now don't tell me I'm
it oh woe to the left huh yeah I'm
really bummed I'm pretty fun pretty
vault this jerk get out of my way it's
just boxing about this yeah pushing
pushing yeah co-op let's work to get oh
[ __ ] come on I got an assist from how
know hey dude he's gonna ruin this first
yeah just wasted my Hydra oh you're dead
you're get your daughter's yeah there's
no point is you didn't see
all right where we will be looking
what's a banner man holding a bear
probably like a [ __ ] door
ooh
uh-oh
it's kind of boring
oh shoot great power comes great
responsible Nino right oh well I did
skin after it buddy Hey look at Stevie
but I mean all right
should be gone out dude the Hydra dude
come on doesn't even really do them Oh
night here just get some nights not to
miss on what the what is that gonna do
[ __ ] get out of here don't even this
crawler might kill me nevermind dude
what I don't know someone keeps shooting
me like on my team get out of here
dealing I'm coming in with a big gun
might be the biggest gun all right yo
weather night ended hi there yes pick up
that pick up that incineration cannon
for me and use it it's right there pick
it up some friend of not going near that
do do you just get it it's a tank
shooting him all that dumb [ __ ] window
I'm gonna steal to kill damn it [ __ ]
alright I'll incinerate him poop and in
the tank
someone's email ate it all the tank
almost but we're not done yet huh nah
what the hell what the hell that's the
dude you were pushing I think he didn't
like you ha my friend doesn't like you I
don't like you either Oh duty Oh
jerkface
incoming Promethean threat I got a
feeling we're gonna see some warden what
do you think yeah that are some like
fate Hans to a bunch of commandos huh
soldier or commando make up your mind
don't just call it both I agree the guy
just promotes himself to soldier
commando assistant to the soldier
commando I have one dude Ted we all know
that's made up oh there's some watchers
in there oh you're right there i love on
the Watchers throw their the nades back
oh god damn it i'm not doing oh I love
that soldier commando yeah it's a cool
thing all right uh shig I want to get
some shoddy in my life Rick confirmed
what
going up going up tears up scratch that
now we're getting the warden oh dude
poopin in the tank again again I wanted
one of those listening he was in there
earlier in the last time we fought a
warden that poop and dude got messed up
through the wall yeah oh my god the
warden is so funny he was just throwing
this guy poop and around in a tank to
van is such a tank man who can there's a
warden looking real hot yeah these
snipers god damn it I regret having a
shotgun now Oh
Oh Dody snipers are so irritating oh
bummer back I was his name [ __ ]
I get out of power weapon please a lot
of people just spawned right near me
we're just dude going too long here we
go nope oh my god fuser bullet sponges
I'm so far away be thrown to spawn damn
how's it going over here I don't know
I'm just trying to kill easy to us to
the right and I didn't touch the box I'm
he freaking tanks we have three four
I have no ambulance
I one last girl
sweet cool sweetie sweetie I well that
uh is firefight uh pretty pretty fun in
general I think the spawning of enemies
can be a little frustrating but the
colorful Spartans Yeah right yeah I
again I love flip saying everyone's hot
armor but uh cool well that's y at
firefight um thanks for watching Mike
thank you for taking a look at this with
me thanks for having me that was good
hehe alright tech see ya see ya